what's popping variants it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show I
cannot tell you how much I love that
dang Loki finale all I truly could not
imagine a more fitting ending for a
reformed God who has coveted a throne
all of his life and seeing Loki
transition from an agent of chaos and
death to a defender of order and life
has been literally one of the most
rewarding Journeys in all of the MCU
especially getting to see that
incredible imagery of Loki converting
the sacred timeline from an Unholy Halo
powered by the illusion of choice to a
beautiful free growing tree of infinite
possibilities today we're going to break
down the science behind Loki's Ascent to
his Cosmic throne and how the Green Glow
of the mcu's new Multiverse Tre relates
to the green time infinity stone so
let's get into it nerd gang all right so
I believe that essentially what we saw
Loki do at the very end of the season 2
finale was become both a living battery
and a Liv living temp pad for the
Multiverse following Loki's dissipation
of that huge explosion of energy that
threatened to destroy the TVA and all of
his friends after Loki uses his Godlike
power over the manipulation of time to
stop the destruction of the exploding
time Loom all of the rainbow strands of
the Multiverse turn black to show how
all the energy from every moment in time
from every Universe in the Multiverse
was beginning to fade away and die
basically being lost to entropy like
I've said before in previous Loki videos
I strongly believe that every single
Universe in the Marvel Cinematic Cosmos
was filled with the same six energy
singularities that also formed the six
Infinity Stones during the big bang with
each of those six energies forming and
representing a key fundamental force of
each Universe based on real life science
for example the blue energy found within
the tessaract was meant to be Marvel
studios's fictional representation of
the real life scientific concept of dark
energy which is basically the completely
invisible force that scientists
attribute the rapid expansion of the
universe to like every single second
since the big bang our real life
universe has been growing bigger and
bigger and higher and further and faster
thanks to the super fast and super
powerful Cosmic expansion power of dark
energy and because of this dark energy
actually makes up a whopping 68% of all
of space which is why Marvel Studios
decid decided to make the space Stone a
dark energy stone that Nick Fury was
studying at the dark energy Mission
facility at the start of Avengers one
and if you understand this then you will
also begin to understand why ego The
Living Planet had his entire life's
Mission be centered around his expansion
because ego was literally just blue dark
energy with a will and since dark energy
is expansion energy ego himself sought
to mirror that with his own expansion
but anyways I digress in fact our our
universe is mainly made up of three main
elements with 68% of it being dark
energy like I said before which the MCU
represents as blue 27% of the universe
being dark matter which the MCU
represents as the red ether infinity
stone chaos magic and black vibranium
with less than 5% of the universe being
normal matter that human beings can see
and interact with which the MCU
represents with the yellow Quantum
energy of the mindstone singularity but
those are just three examples anyways
because every universe is comprised of
these six energies every thread on the
sacred timeline had the multicolored
glow of a rainbow until the explosion of
the time Loom caused all the infinity
energy from every Universe to start
dying simultaneously which basically
meant that every atom in existence
started to fizzle out in every timeline
causing each to become filled with the
same primordial nothingness that the
cosmos of light was originally born from
before the Big Bang by attaching himself
to all of the threads of the Multiverse
and shooting his green magic through
those threads Loki was trying to reverse
the entropy of the universe by using his
own inner stores of massive amounts of
Godlike Infinity energy in order to keep
the Multiverse alive as he slowly made
his way to his throne because it is that
very Throne that is the most important
piece of cosmic technology absolutely
crucial to helping Loki power his new
multiversal tree mostly because Loki's
throne and and Loki's horns are made up
of the same big ass chunk of black and
gold rock that made up the Citadel at
the End of Time the same exact type of
black and gold rock that he who remains
his master temp pad was made out of this
is important because I believe this
black and gold material has been seen in
the MCU before with the black part of
the rock that made up the majority of
the asteroid and the Citadel that sat a
top of that asteroid likely being
vibranium as dark matter vibranium has
historically been as absorbent as it is
durable which is why it is one of the
few things in the universe that can
survive constant bombardment by the
super hot rainbow radiation shooting out
of the Sacred timeline at all times for
countless Millennia and it's pretty much
why when we first see the Citadel last
season the radiation from the timeline
can be seen radiating out of the very
Rock itself showing that this dark Rock
has absorbed the rainbow power of
infinity creation energy inside of it
but that's just the black part of that
asteroid now let's talk about the golden
part that seems to react to Loki as soon
as Loki starts walking on the ruins of
he who remains a citadel because that
gold power is part of an energy that has
been present in the MCU before most
notably in both Ant-Man and the was
quantam Mania as well as the eternals
movie because this golden energy is the
yellow energy of the Mind Singularity
the power of mind and physical Atomic
matter in the MCU also known as Quantum
energy the same golden energy of the
mindstone in Quantum Mania Quantum
energy was Central to Kang's goals
because the golden yellow energy was
literally what powered Kang's golden
time chair but not only this but Janet
vany herself would learn that the energy
that ran through Kang's chair was
neurokinetic when touching the yellow
mind Singularity energy in the chair
allowed her to connect to Kang's mind
and see his memories and in eternals the
golden energy that powered the eternals
themselves is also what allowed the
eternals to connect their minds together
to form the unim mind that would end up
amplifying cersei's powers to even
higher degrees than they became after
she was given that golden Celestial
communication sphere from ajax's
lifeless corpse this all being said I
believe that all the infinity energy the
dark vibranium has stored by being in
close proximity to the sacred timeline
combined with the neurokinetic golden
Quantum Mind energy that has been linked
to amplifying powers in the past is
exactly what allowed Loki to have the
power to form his new cosmic multiversal
tree because I believe that without The
Golden Throne connected to that huge
mass of vibranium Loki would not have
been able to Source the infinity energy
necessary to bring all of the energy of
every Universe back to life on his own
because as we saw as he approached the
throne that boy was struggling he could
not do it on his own it is the very
Throne interfacing with Loki's mind that
allowed Loki the power to make his
multiversal idrasil with nothing but a
thought the branches of his multiversal
tree literally became an extension of
Loki's neural network which is why he
was able to hear Mobius talk to Sylvie
at the very end of the episode along
with pretty much anything else in the
MCU Multiverse he's literally the mcu's
God by becoming a living version of he
who remains his temp pad so he could
become the benevolent heart of the
Multiverse itself but the reason why
Loki's Multiverse tree is Green is is
not just to represent Loki's magic
holding the rainbow threads of the
timeline together much like we can see
in close-up shots of the timelines but
also to represent the green time
Singularity of the MCU a singularity
closely tied to the fundamental force of
gravity in our universe because much
like in our real life gravity is Central
to time and actually determines the flow
of time this is one of the biggest
reasons why the entire sacred timeline
was situated inside of a giant
gravitational anomaly that was a black
hole a black hole that was quick to turn
people into spaghetti if they didn't
have a suit capable of withstanding the
immense gravitational pressures of that
environment green energy has been used
to denote gravity in past MCU films much
like it did with the villain yon rag
using his green gravity gauntlets in
Captain Marvel Doctor Strange using the
gravity Stone against celius and doramu
when he wanted to manipulate time with
the time Stone and even shangi himself
appears to wear a green gravity Stone
necklace given to him by his mother who
secretly trained him how to manipulate
gravity with that stone in the same way
that wenwu ended up using shun's green
necklace in order to make all that water
float at his house and is because of
that same green necklace that shanii is
able to make his 10 Rings float thanks
to that training from his mom in his
childhood as well as his quick training
session with his aunt before the big
fight but anyways in the same vein Loki
has used his green gravity powers in the
past to repel people away and even used
it last season to keep a building from
falling on top of him during an
apocalypse on lenus the invisible stairs
that Loki makes for himself on his way
to the throne during the season 2 finale
appear to be an extension of his gravity
manipulation Powers but anyways by using
a combination of Science and fiction it
seems like Loki was able to use the
green infinity Singularity that ran
through his body in order to inject
surges of raw Green Time energy into the
timeline branches in order to bring the
Multiverse back to life and give the
Multiverse a fighting chance to defy the
chaotic fate that he who remains planned
for it all but anyways before we wrap up
this video I do want to talk about
whether or not the tree that Loki made
in the season 2 finale was actually the
very same igil that we were introduced
to in the first Thor movie because a lot
of people on the internet seemed to
believe that Loki created igdrasil when
he revived and rearranged the strands
that used to make up he who remains a
sacred timeline however given what has
been previously established about igil
in the MCU as well as igr's roots in
North mythology that does not seem very
likely much like Thor tells Jane Foster
in the first Thor movie uril has always
been meant to represent the nine main
Cosmic districts that comprise the 616
Universe this being the case each of the
nine Realms in the Marvel Universe can
be traveled via spaceship you just have
to have a really good spaceship that is
able to make massive consecutive warp
jumps at Jump points scattered
throughout the Universe to get to any
realm that you want or even a light
speeed engine like we see in Captain
Marvel effectively making all the Norse
gods of all the Realms aliens from the
perspective of the average person living
on MCU 616 Earth the Norse gods called
idrasil the world tree because it is how
they chose to map out the structure of
the universe that they watched over with
the occasional lining up of the nine
Realms every 5,000 years called the
convergence likely serving as
inspiration for them adopting the tree
symbolism in the MCU because that is
when all the nine Realms line up
perfectly kind of like a tree but that
all being said the idril that Loki and
the gods of Asgard have come to know is
strictly a concept localized to a
specific universe and not one that was
originally meant to cover a multiversal
scope so the new tree that Loki made in
the finale was merely Loki taking
inspiration from his Norse mythological
roots and structuring his new Multiverse
after the only other Cosmic structure
that he knew the igdrasil of his home
universe that he wanted so badly to rule
over in the past so to be clear the igil
that Loki made in the season 2 finale is
not the same igil that comprises the
nine Realms what Loki made was a
Multiverse tree and the idrasil from
Norse mythology is specifically a tree
for the worlds the planets of the
universe so these are two different
versions of igdrasil that we're seeing
in the MCU but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment on Twitter
if you guys want to see me tweet some
weird and really fun theories but
most importantly follow heavy spoilers
here on YouTube and wherever we are on
the social medias to keep up to date
with everything that we do also if you
like the video feel free to give this
video a thumbs up because that always
helps the channel but again thank you
guys so much for watching I love you
guys so much and I'll see you guys later
goodbye